reach
mr speaker this new blueprint delivers
three
high-speed lines first that's crew to
manchester second birmingham to the east
midlands with hs2 trains continuing to
central nottingham and central derby
chesterfield and sheffield on an
upgraded main line and third a brand new
high-speed line from warrington to
manchester and to the western border of
yorkshire slashing journey times across
the north
mr speaker
mr speaker
well
mr figger i know they'll want to hear
the detail
of those journey times and they'll also
want to explain
why their constituents would wish to
wait
would wish to wait decades more to
deliver a journey almost no faster at
all than these plans today so mr speaker
i've heard some people say uh that we're
we're just going about and this is i
think their point electrifying uh the
transpanine route this is wrong what
we're actually doing is investing 23
billion pounds to deliver northern
powerhouse rail and the transparent
route upgrade unlocking east-west travel
across the north of england so in total
this package is 110 miles of new
high-speed line
all of it in the midlands and the north
it's 180 miles of newly electrified line
all of it in the midlands and the north
i just remember reminding the honourable
gentleman of their 63 miles of
electrified line in 13 years
uh we'll upgrade the east coast mainline
with a package of investment on track
improvements and digital signaling
bringing down journey times between
london leeds darlington newcastle and
edinburgh bringing benefits to the
northeast much much sooner than under
the previous plans and it adds capacity
and speeds of services
over more than 400 miles of lines the
vast majority of it in the midlands and
the north
we'll study how best to take hs2 trains
into leeds as well and we'll start work
on the new west yorkshire mass transit
system
righting the wrong
of this major city probably the largest
in europe which doesn't have a mass
transit system we commit today to
supporting west yorkshire combined
authority over the long term to ensure
that this time it actually gets done
in short mr speaker we're about to
embark on one of the biggest single acts
of leveling up of any government in
history
well listen to the numbers well listen
to the numbers it's five times more than
was spent on crossrail it's ten times
more than was spent on delivering the
olympics but they still think it's a
small package mr speaker
it will achieve the same similar or
faster journey times to london and on
the core northern powerhouse network
than the original proposals and will
bring the benefits years earlier as we
double in some case cases triple the
capacity so let me just set out a few of
these investments
rail journeys between birmingham and
nottingham cut from an hour and a
quarter to 26 minutes city centre to
city centre journeys between york and
manchester down to 55 minutes from 83
minutes today commuters will be able to
get from bradford to leeds in just 12
minutes almost half the time it takes
today there'll be earlier benefits for
places like sheffield and chesterfield
trips from newcastle to birmingham will
be slashed by almost 30 minutes and
passengers in durham and darlington will
benefit from smoother more reliable
trains as the irp delivers not just for
our largest cities but also for smaller
places and towns for example kettering
market harbor leicester loughborough
grantham newark redford doncaster
wakefield gooseberry
huddersfield staley bridge they could
all see improvements electrification
faster services benefiting
in ways that they would not have done
under the original hs2 program mr
speaker we're not stopping there today's
plan is about those places which connect
and interact with hs2 and northern
powerhouse rail so the scale of ambition
with many of these projects uh lying
outside of the scope so just yesterday i
opened the first beaching reversal uh
reversing the beaching axe uh and we are
going to be doing the same in
northumberland from washington blithe
newcastle line and many others we're
investing 2 billion in cycling water
walking 3 billion
in turn up and go bus services and tens
of billions in our country's roads so mr
speaker after decades of decline with
constrained capacity and poor
reliability finally this plan will give
passengers and the north and the
midlands the service they need and they
deserve it's not just about
infrastructure we're going to make train
travel much easier as well today i can
confirm 360 million pounds to reform
fares and ticketing with a roll out of
contactless pay-as-you-go ticketing to
700 urban stations including 400 in the
north mr speaker is a landmark plan far
by far by far the biggest
of any network improvement and focused
on the north and midlands with more
seats more frequent services shorter
journeys it meets the needs of today's
passengers and the future generations
and we're getting started immediately